that's what josée thinks Peter greens
tweeted me already to say the managers
word is final if she doesn't like it
leave joining us to talk about it
further central London sports journalist
Natasha Henry and here with me in the
studio is the broadcaster male innopolis
let's turn to you Natasha first of all
if I may you think he's in the wrong I
do think he's in the wrong 100% why um I
think I'm a big believer if you have a
problem with your staff then you deal
with it in-house first and foremost and
secondly he needs to understand their
job as much as they need to understand
his if the medical team hadn't gone onto
the field they would have been breaking
rules of the British Medical Council so
would he rather that they didn't do
their job and just abide it to what he
feels is right or would he prefer that
they did their job and made sure that
the health and safety of the player was
the most important thing Marlo I don't
know I have to excite different of you
on this I kind of get the impression
behind a lot of the reporting here that
people are trying to make this into a
slightly a gender issue I'm not sure why
we're really even hearing about it I
mean thank God for the drama in football
because if it weren't the drama in
football and it was so unnaturally
boring football is a game in any case
was a women in homosexuals it's just so
so dull Susan women's football is
tolerable because it's so close to ready
- this is an incredibly boring thing I
don't get why we're talking about this
at all except for the fact that every
time a woman seems to get fired or
sidelined and it seems to become a
gender issue it's almost like men are
sort of anxious to whiteknight her and I
wonder about the message this sends out
that women sometimes somehow need this
help he's the Manager you know the game
of football revolves around the off
pitch drama it is entirely up to him
whether he wants to fire or you know or
hire people they are known for being
mercurial and difficult and it seems to
me that you know we're only hearing
about this because this woman happens to
have a pair of breasts Natasha and
personally I'm I'm not buying into the
he's sexist that's not at all my issue
with it my issue with it is that she's a
medically trained doctor very very well
trained very successful and experienced
and I just feel whether she was a man or
a woman
his attitude towards a lot of people is
disrespectful I just don't see how
demoting someone is supporting them as a
member of your staff now if it came down
to it choices josée probably changed for
trained for three years to do his job
she trained for eight so I think all
medical staff regardless of who they
work for deserve a bit more respect
Martin
Turner's tweeted to Milo to say that
Eden has out who's the player on on the
floor he surely should have known the
rules as well why blame the doctor what
I think anyone's blaming the doctor or
they're suggesting is that it is the
manager the you know the coaches are
prerogative to do exactly as he pleases
and my question the beginning was simply
why we're hearing about this why is this
news why is this interesting why so many
people talking about it there's an
underlying red thread here which I'm a
bit suspicious about and you know at
training periods whether she was
training for eight years to be a doctor
seems to me to be entirely irrelevant
you know the fact is he's made a
decision about his team and you know
she's been very gracious about it it's
not her that is driving this
extraordinary and mystifying controversy
she was very gracious on Facebook she
said you know thanks for the support but
didn't go into any of the details didn't
go into you know whether or not she felt
that the decision was fair she simply
she was nice about it seems to be the
media that are making this a sauna I
still can't work out why and I'm getting
a sense that readers from comment
sections online from Twitter are also
wondering why is this a story why every
time a woman you know is demoted or has
a tough time at work do we make it an
issue of you know make it into an issue
even if we don't use the S word it's
very peculiar and you know frankly it's
got nothing to do with how long she
trained how long he trained it's got
nothing to do with you know there would
be you know any particular commentators
assessment of whether she was right or
not to head on to the pitch he made a
decision it is essential you know for
the functioning of the football industry
as we know it that these mercurial you
know dictators are allowed to behave
like this it's what people read the
sports pages for after all and you know
I just don't understand why we're
talking about it what as far as you're
concerned in a Cheshire I mean surely it
is up to the manager he decides who sits
pitch side and who doesn't and on
occasion as we as we know in the past
when he's overstepped the mark he's been
forced to move
way from the side of the pitch so it's
up to the manager to choose oh I have no
problem with him deciding who he wants
on the bench next to him it's the way he
deals with things this is a story to
respond to my life it's a story because
it's Joe Marini oh and one thing Josie
is known for is drawing attention away
from his team when they've actually been
quite disappointing we've seen him blame
referees the weather lines people even
ball boys have been at fault when
Chelsea haven't performed as they should
do and that's why it's a story it's a
story because rather than talking about
the inability of his team the current
champions to beat Swansea at home he
decided to explain to us why he was
showing that his medical staff he could
have said that for watch football for
isn't it I mean this is why people watch
football it's for all the hissy fits and
drama you know this is a sport for
people who love a bit of drama it's a
sport for people who you know aren't
necessarily particularly interested in
athleticism I mean it's a sport for
people who've perhaps some aren't into
really properly manly games like hockey
ice hockey or or American okay let me
take you to the emesis and let's see if
people that hate more take people who
live for off pitch drama and what they
live for
what Murray do what Mourinho does is no
different to what the players do on the
pitch when they dive you know and so we
just kind of feel for in a sense it's
very difficult for a doctor to know
whether or not you know a player is
genuinely in pain because you know these
these men are such theatrical divas you
know and and I think he's well within
his rights to make a judgment about
whether or not it was a good decision of
hers and I know the referee called her
onto the pitch she was following the
rules that she normally fought follows
referees always right about everything
she doesn't know when he's leg or not
the referees are never wrong about
anything no um I'd say she did her job
that's what she did in the same way that
your boss calls you and says can you
actually do me thousand words today in
the referee called onto the pitch that
she did her job in the judgment of her
boss she you know she is even not her
boss Roman Abramovich is her boss
okay so Mourinho is the manager of the
team not the manager of the staff around
him well presumably if he weren't her
boss he wouldn't be able to sideline her
in the way that he has with the order
mate he may have used the words but it's
not his order it's down to people
Bob Daisley to make the decisions just
as it is whether he can spend money
which he hasn't which is why he's thrown
his toys out of the pram you see come
you're getting struggle now because
we're talking about football and you
know nothing about it do you my own
sense that's ridiculous I told you it's
a game for women homosexuals so
obviously I've been to lots of make sure
who's your team then well I'm there yeah
yeah yes merciful probably a Chelsea guy
who is your team Natasha I'm an Arsenal
fan ah good girl and what do you think
that Vanga would ever do this
I beg as well known for trying to keep
issues in-house he's a little well for
him he doesn't abuse his players in
public so it's very unlikely he would
abuse his staff in public maybe if he
did a snow would be doing a bit better
Oh see he literally knows nothing about
either form attention one gay well let's
not even talk to him about the European
League should we we must leave it there
thank you so much adieu to both of you
for joining us here oh that guy uses
afternoon thank you just to remind you
of course that Tottenham Hotspur did not
qualify for your